- Do something that's
really authentic to you
and that you genuinely want to, like,
breathe, sleep, dream about.
I get up every day at like 6:00 a.m.
My journey is longer than others.
But for me, it's a lifestyle.
I believe in making lifestyle changes,
in doing things for you.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
It's Evan.
My one word is believe.
And I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
And my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from entrepreneur
and TV personality, Khloe Kardashian,
and my take on her top
ten rules to success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
Also, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired by it as well.
And if you leave it within
the first couple of hours
of this video going live,
you have a chance to win
one of two daily prizes.
(sound effects)
(upbeat music)
- Do something that's
really authentic to you
and that you genuinely want to, like,
breathe, sleep, dream, about.
Like I am super passionate
about Good American,
but also just for what it
represents and stands for.
And then I also think that reads through.
I think anything that we do
- Quite right.
- that's truly a part of our heart,
that's when you have the longevity
because you care so much about it.
It's your baby.
I get up every day at like 6 a.m.
And it's just because my mom
always made us have responsibilities.
Doesn't matter how much money
someone has or doesn't have.
You have to teach, especially
the more money you have,
is the laser you become.
- Yes.
- So teach people to have
structure and good work ethics.
That's what makes you a better person.
So my mom has always done that,
always made us have responsibilities.
And I think it pays off later in life...
- Khloe Kardashian says,
"I personally felt I
was beautiful bigger."
- Mm-hmm.
- Is that true?
- Well, I never felt that I was ever big.
I never looked at myself like,
"Oh, my God, I was the fat one.
Other people called me that,
so I would say it to like
beat them to the punch.
Like, "Okay, I'm the fat funny one."
So I was like, "I am so cute."
Go into this club in
this really tight dress.
Like, Kim would wear the same dresses.
They would always do a side-by-side.
"Who wore it better?"
I'm like, "You know who wore it better.
It was Kim, but..."
- (laughs)
- I felt so good.
- Where does that confidence
for that body image come from?
Because it's very hard.
I think there are a lot of girls out there
who struggle with that.
So how do they get that Khloe confidence?
- You know, it's...
- With a K.
- Yeah, Khloe confidence with a K.
- (laughs)
It really comes from like
loving yourself from within.
- Mm-hmm.
If Instagram were to take
a picture of your soul,
what would that look like?
I know my soul is beautiful.
I know I'm a good person.
But that came from fat Khloe
and that's going to
come from skinny Khloe.
Like that will never change for me.
When I was going through my divorce,
I really was stressed out,
like just needed a place to go.
And I knew if...
We're so close, my family and I.
So I didn't want to keep
going to my mom's house
and it would be like suspect, like,
"What's going on with you?"
So I turned to the gym.
And I loved just
being on the elliptical and watching TV.
And like really, just, it was working out.
And then I realized how good
I felt just doing cardio.
Like afterwards, how clear my mind felt.
- Mm-hmm.
- And then by that, I was like, "Oh wait!
And as a by-product, I
started losing weight.
But it wasn't my goal at first.
And then I would say after
a few months, I was like,
"You know I'm going to
take this thing seriously."
So I got my trainer, Gunnar Peterson,
and he's badass.
So then I was like, "Okay, wait.
This is really hard and serious."
But I took baby steps.
So my journey is longer than others,
but for me, it's a lifestyle,
because my whole life, I
was an emotional eater,
and I did not have any
of this under control.
So it was new for me.
So I took baby steps in doing that.
So I would say towards
like my divorce era.
But it took a minute
for me to then be like,
"Okay, I'm going to take this seriously."
- You get addicted to the results.
- Mm-hmm.
- And then you think, "Okay,
I'm going to keep going."
- Definitely.
- I met Emma.
I'm really big on energy and how
I like someone that I want
to be in business with.
And I'm not here for the short term.
I want something that
has longevity and legs.
And I met Emma and we
just completely clicked.
And it's not about
having a new denim line.
It was about doing something
that empowers other women
and something that is really
going to break down barriers.
And I'm all for woman empowerment.
And I used to be someone that
they would label as plus-size.
And I'm
like that.
I don't want to be called that.
Like, I'm a woman with curves,
and I'm what I would say is
average size at the time.
And I was very proud of who I was.
And I felt like so shamed at the time
to go into boutiques or
to go denim shopping.
It was something that
was super hard for me.
So when I met Emma,
and she was all for
everything that I stood for,
I was like, "That's a badass woman,
and I want to be in business with her.
And then when everything that she said
in our initial meeting actually happened,
and all of our meetings took place,
and we were able to have this great line
that stood for, not just jeans,
it stood for making other people
feel good about themselves
and women not having to be segregated,
where this size has to go to
this side of the shopping center
and these women who go to this side.
Like that's not what I wanted.
So that's really something that was
authentic to me and that I stood behind
and that I felt like could be a movement
and hopefully, encourage other brands
to follow in our footsteps.
- Nowadays, with social
media, it's way more intense.
I really love the whole blocking thing
on Instagram these days.
And I am using it every second.
I love it.
I love to take social media breaks.
Like I'll post things and
try not to read the comments,
because if I was posting
something about me,
I post something with me,
like raising money for cancer awareness,
and I got reamed for it.
So it's like no matter what I do,
you're going to have just haters.
So just know that that's
the way of the world
and just love yourself.
- What really inspired this whole,
"Be the best me."
"Get myself in shape," and
look like this?
- Thank you.
- What inspired that moment?
- I believe in making lifestyle changes,
in doing things for you.
- Right.
- I don't know.
I've always worked out, but
I just never found my groove.
- Right.
- And then when I was
going through my divorce,
I was super stressed.
I didn't really know what to do.
And I was just like,
"Well, when my dad died,
I like turned to drinking,
- Right.
and like really destructive behavior.
- So I was like, "I don't
want to go back there."
I just kind of found my refuge.
My place of refuge was the gym.
- You've been obviously working out.
Like, what is your thing?
What's your main thing that you do?
'Cause you look terrific.
- Well, thank you.
Well, for me, it's
about lifestyle changes.
I've dieted forever.
I'm a yo-yo dieter, yo-yo weight gainer.
And I was like, "Okay, I
need to make a change."
It's not about doing it...
like losing 30 pounds in 30 days.
That's unrealistic.
So I started making lifestyle
changes and working out often.
I started slow.
It's been like about three years,
and I've kept the weight off.
But I've lost, I don't know,
I don't weigh myself,
but I've lost about 40 pounds,
- Wow.
- but over three years.
(applause)
I'm glad you said you've been
working at this for three years,
and it's a lifestyle change.
Because a lot of people say,
"I've been working out for three days.
- Right, right.
I don't see the difference."
- But it is a long--
It takes time.
- Yeah.
And it's discouraging.
I mean, for the first two months,
I was like, what--
I am sweating.
I'm busting my ass.
I'm tired.
I'm hungry.
- Yeah.
- I'm just, whatever.
And you don't notice anything.
But you just keep on going.
Obviously, something's going to happen.
But your body takes a minute
for that change to show.
- Yeah, of course.
- The tortoise wins the race.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
So that's what I want to do.
And I want to keep it off forever.
- When I was first starting out,
we used to get pitched
things all the time,
and we're like bright-eyed and,
"Oh, my God, that's so exciting."
And you're new and you do
take on a lot of things
that maybe aren't as
authentic or true to you
or you don't really believe in.
I think you're young and excited.
But by doing that, I've
made a lot of mistakes,
but which made me better for today.
- I think that your honesty on screen
Mm-hmm.
- is so engaging.
- Thank you.
- And I think you've become a
role model for younger girls,
- Thank you.
- which I imagine is a hard mantle.
- Yeah.
- How do you deal with that?
- Well, I mean, I think if
you think about everything,
that it's going to become
overwhelming and it might be scary.
But I don't think of it like that.
I think about--
I think for my little sisters
and for my nieces and nephews
how I want them to perceive me,
and what I want the
message to be for them.
And then hopefully that
message is good enough
for the rest of the world
if I want my loved ones to have it.
But it's really just, I mean,
being a strong mind, body soul,
and just knowing that there's
so much more out there than social media.
And I think that's what people,
especially the youth, get.
- Mm-hmm.
They get so wrapped up in social media
and trying to appeal to
people they don't even know.
And you have to just make yourself happy.
(triumphant music)
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Generation Y asked me to.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in our future Top Ten,
please check out the link
down in the description below
and you can cast your vote
on who we should do next.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Vijay Raj.
Vijay, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and posting multiple videos
on your YouTube channel about it.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support.
And I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
- Your mindset for greatness
leads to your one word,
so that you're standing
for something important.
- Thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(sound effects)
I think success for me is longevity.
Like, I don't want this
to be around this year
and no one knows about it in five years.
Like I would like this to be a brand
that really grows roots
and is here for like
years and years to come.
And again, who knows?
Good American is a name
that could venture off
to men or children or whatever.
But I'm just excited
to see where that goes.
And it's absolutely outrageous
the positive reaction we've gotten.
And it's so, it just makes me like
so proud and excited and like, it's...
I'm just so happy.
But it is like I'm dreaming.
So I'm excited just to
baby this a little bit,
and then see where it goes.
(sound effects)